this video is sponsored by one punch man
road to hero 2.0
yo ho ho thriller bark is bananas but
one thing i can say for certain is that
for me
this wasn't the best arc so far now
that's not to say that there aren't good
great or even peak one piece moments
dotted throughout
but for a crucial part of the overall
story being told i found myself much
less invested or interested in what was
happening on screen
i still liked a lot of stuff but damn
some aspects really didn't do it for me
and by the time things were wrapping up
with the main story i was
getting kinda bored but like a phoenix
rising from the flames at the speed of
light
this story immediately after returns to
peak one piece
again so what did i think of it well
grab your favorite tim burton posters
some pumpkin pie and a whole
bunch of patience because i'm totally
not mark and this is my first
impressions of
thoughts on and review four a creative
albeit
slightly messy spooktastic adventure on
thriller bark but before we dive into
the material for this week's video i
want to quickly thank and talk about
today's sport
one punch man road to hero 2.0 is an
officially licensed strategy card mobile
game of the rpg variety
featuring the voice acting and storyline
from the hit anime one punch man you
know you might have heard of it who's in
it
saitama jenna sporos and even that weird
krablante guys in it you can even see
those drawn on nipples with markers now
that's attention to detail
this game's got over 50 heroes to
collect it's got tournament pvp it's got
puzzle modes mission modes boss fights
and knee i stress it's got krav lante's
fake
marker i've personally had a blast
playing it between chapters over the
last week and if you'd like to get your
hands on it too
with some perks while also helping out
the channel
download one punch man via the links in
my description and enter the code zero
to hero
to get a special bonus 10 free recruit
tokens for one
multi summit so what are you waiting for
collect those heroes unleash your epic
ultimates and show me what it means to
be a hero for fun
and for god's sake send me screenshots
of you finding krablante's marker
nipples on twitter
alright back to the video
okay so just to be upfront with you guys
while there were aspects
of this arc i really and i mean really
liked there was a relatively large
section of this story that i would
consider to be important
that to be honest didn't really work for
me and i will be explaining in detail
why i both enjoyed and didn't like
certain parts of this arc
but i just want to make one thing clear
before i do whether you hate
everything about this arc or whether
it's your favorite my opinions in this
video aren't more important than anyone
else's these are just my first
impressions
nothing more with that said i will give
reasons for every single take i have
regarding the story of thriller bark and
why it was for me
the first moment oda actually felt human
in the entire story of one piece
i mean it took almost half a thousand
chapters to get to what i thought was a
bad chapter so it's ridiculously
impressive i managed to get this far
without complaining
those who've seen my dragon ball gt
videos know exactly what i'm talking
about here
thriller bark is essentially a mystery
adventure rescue story focusing on a
very different theme that becomes
unavoidably obvious when we arrive
on thriller bark and while i will have a
bit to talk about regarding portions
that i didn't like
i actually enjoyed a considerable amount
of the core story told
here specifically the beginning and the
middle so let's talk about what i really
enjoyed in this arc first before i
discuss the things i thought could have
been reworked a bit more
kicking things off i thoroughly enjoyed
the fact that oda gave us time to enjoy
the crew
in their new ship during which they come
across a literal mystery box in the
ocean that once opened sends up a giant
flare
at this point i knew what was coming but
i really liked it nevertheless
almost immediately after a ghost ship
carrying within it a living skeleton
called brook
floats on by and almost immediately
after meeting luffy he asks him to join
his crew to which
brook says yes of course while i thought
this was in character for luffy to do
it distinctly didn't feel like an earned
addition to the crew
and i think that's by design and
thankfully this greatly changes
throughout but what i found
really interesting about this sudden
recruitment was that despite having been
offered and having accepted the position
at the beginning of the next five
volumes to come which covers the
entirety of thriller bark
brooke isn't at all featured as a straw
hat towards the front of the books
which honestly acts as a nice bit of
foreshadowing regarding what happens
later regarding brook's flashback in
past
so i really really liked that but to be
honest
from the get-go with the character of
brook i wasn't overly fond of him
i don't particularly like perverted
characters and from the outset
he seemed to be much more raunchy than
sanji was that is
until later in the story but don't worry
i'll get to that ignoring that for now
brooke thankfully becomes a much
deeper more interesting character full
of unique problems that tie
very much into the history of the
established story within one piece the
presence and introduction of brook
however in this instance is less about
the crew thinking they've recruited him
and more about what he means for the
story he goes on to explain why he is
the way that he is due to a devil fruit
he consumed giving him a second chance
at life and also points out that a
sinister someone has taken away his
shadow and thus cannot go into direct
sunlight without dying
also every second line he speaks is upon
soon after coming across brooke the ship
gets dragged into thriller bark
a massive island floating in the middle
of the ocean surrounded by fog
immediately an ominous tone is
established successfully leading to
brook immediately running away across
the water which is
on its own an interesting thing to see
but what i love about this beginning can
be seen
immediately after apparently the flare
sent up earlier was a signal to this
place known as
thriller park to take their ship apart
from this beginning setting up a
specific goal in retrieving the lost
shadow of brook
apart from paying off the barrel in a
successful manner what i love is that
while approaching this new island
oda takes the time to explore the new
improvements seen to the thousand sunny
demonstrating a bunch of new features
courtesy of frankie
one in particular being a small tribute
to the mary that and this is the awesome
part
connects the crew with the threat of
thriller park itself
creating a whole bunch of motivation and
tension for the story additionally
something i thought was really clever
before exploring thriller bark was how
oda establishes right away
who among the crew doesn't want to
investigate the spooky spooky island and
who
does chopper nami and usop are those
such people that want nothing to do with
it but when out-testing the new mini
merry craft
they don't come back leading those on
the ship who did want to go investigate
i.e the most competent people left
worried for their safety
now we have two goals as a reader get
the shadows back to restore brook back
to normal despite him
after running away and to retrieve the
now lost crew
the second goal is exceptionally
important as it gives the characters a
reason to explore the new island and to
establish the surroundings for the
reader while also attempting to fulfill
the narrative goal it's a fun idea that
works i think
extremely well after this point there's
just a whole mess of mystery and
conflict
and from this point we start slipping
into the second act of the story which
takes up a large chunk
of the overall narrative which i also
largely really enjoyed the same way i
did at the earlier parts of the story
small character moments through nico
robin demonstrating that she loves
adventure and isn't scared of much
proving to be much more curious and less
scared than anything else is exactly
what i was hoping for from her helping
her feel very distinct from nami too
what's more and something i referred to
multiple videos ago during the skypier
arc was how robin would refer to
everyone not by their name but by some
other impersonal moniker
like big nose referring to usop or
navigator referring to nami
however now in contrast to that robin
refers to
everyone by their name after the events
of any lobby it's incredibly subtle and
so easily missed but for those that
do notice it really helps these
characters feel all the more human and
likable
with this specific instance of that
satisfying that she is allowing herself
to get close to these friends
it's a beautiful thing to see and
honestly really appreciate it and
following this little nugget as readers
we are bombarded by information of this
world and its inhabitants watching as
the gang get
ambushed attacked stalked kidnapped and
all the other things
featuring classic horror tropes and
favorites like ghosts zombies the
invisible man and even frankenstein sort
of much
much later which is a really cool idea
on paper to build your story around
if nothing else this arc certainly has
its own unique voice and feels distinct
from literally
everything else i've come across thus
far in the story of one piece which is
something i also very much enjoyed but
this section of the main story i believe
is the absolute
strongest part so let's break down why i
thought this was really effective and
clever as i explained earlier oda took
the time to establish who among the crew
wanted to explore the island he then
took those among them who didn't want to
explore it and sent them in first to
discover
everything as it's always more fun to
watch those uncomfortable in a situation
try to figure it out and stay cool
through them we meet a three-headed
beast some zombies then a whole host of
monsters
before arriving at a haunted house where
they made another key character called
dr hogbach
in this haunted house a whole bunch of
crazy stuff happens to them as we watch
the less scared portion of the crew led
by luffy
experience the exact same tribulations
but in a much more funny way due to
their not being scared
this is enjoyable to watch only because
we are comparing it to usop nami and
choppers experiences with them
circumstances like this reinforce
character for both parties
and i found to be massively entertaining
i specifically burst out laughing as i
watched luffy shove a
zombie back into the ground i don't
think i've ever seen someone try to do
that before and when i saw it i just
burst into tears laughing
once luffy is done doing the rubber man
hokey pokey all over these
the gang encounter a man that gives us
our first taste of the most important
character in this arc
one of the seven warlords of the sea
gecko moria
and in what becomes a really nice swerve
in the story the floating island of
thriller park
happened to be the largest ship in the
world captained by
none other than mr moria himself that
moment in particular was a moment i sort
of kicked myself for not predicting
sooner
sanji zora and luffy in a really
unexpected turn of events
all get their shadows gobbled up and
placed into other
zombies those zombies now all have their
powers and for the time being
all those that had their shadows stolen
are unconscious back at the ship
this leaves just frankie and robin the
two newest additions to the crew
to demonstrate what they are made of and
allows them to get more time in the
spotlight which i
really really enjoyed also there's this
super creepy spider monkey thing that is
absolutely terrifying and totally the
stuff of nightmares and on top of that
robin can fly sort of question mark so
that's pretty tight not gonna lie about
that
and also this is sort of tangential to
everything that i've been saying thus
far but
i had to address it here the amount of
times that this particular arc mentions
quote
the new world was quite striking which i
suppose tells me that we're going to be
going there at some point
so i'm going to leave that chekhov's
going right there for the time being
anyways to cut a long story short
luffy's shadow is thrown into this giant
ice monster that is way bigger than a
typical giant should be
and in a fun turn of events when the
shadows are absorbed initially the
residual personality of the shadow's
owners
takes over the zombie's vessel for a
certain amount of time which
leads to a really interesting dynamic
the crew have to later face
they have to fight a giant luffy the
shadow absorption mechanic is cool and
everything but it comes with a
restriction that required moria not to
take out sanji
luffy and zorro and so they left him on
the ship ready to reconvene with the
rest of the crew once they made their
escape
so at this time nami is still captured
by a really awful
awful character that i hate and luffy's
shadow is acting like a fool everywhere
a bunch of the crew are missing their
shadows and so a new deadline is
introduced to create suspense
and it does it quite effectively and
that deadline is
sunrise since they lost their shadows
the sun will now kill them if it hits
them
them being the strongest fighters in the
straw hats
so sort of a big old deal with this
problem now facing them luffy shines
like the true main character he is
opting to go straight to the root of the
problem moria citing that if he can beat
him
the shadows will return to their normal
owners it's another wonderful example of
luffy adding to the story by being so
straightforward and clear-cut
wanting to take out the problem at its
source by taking out one of the warlords
of the sea
and while luffy is left to pursue this
course of action the rest of the crew
decide to take out
individual zombies looking for their own
shadows respectively to act as a sort of
contingency plan in case luffy's doesn't
work out and with the added mission of
still rescuing nami
during this portion with the straw hats
there are four secondary fights that
take place against the underlings of
moria and i love
three of them i'll save the other one
for a later point in the video so
let's start with chopper versus dr
hogbach
i haven't really spoken about him too
much in this video but dr hogbach up
until this point has been the villain
that has honestly had the most buildup
and
backstory explained to us he's actively
lied to every one of the straw hats he's
met
put them all in danger kidnapped people
and has resurrected their
corpses using moria's powers the place
exists because of him and so
needless to say i was more than invested
in seeing this psychopath get
taken down along with his warped view of
how morality and the world works
additionally chopper i thought was an
ideal candidate to face off against this
guy as
not only are they both doctors not only
was dr hogbach established to be a huge
inspiration to chopper while he was
studying medicine but
also because their philosophies as it
pertains to helping people
are polar opposites as we learn dr
hogbach's motivations are entirely
driven by greed
highlighted through the character of
syndry who he specifically rose from the
dead just to serve
and be with him despite her utter
refusal to do the exact same thing when
she was alive
which is just all sorts of messed up and
provides a more than interesting through
line for chopper to work with alongside
robin in a tag team effort
against them and perhaps the most
interesting aspect of this fight was the
internal struggle syndry was fighting to
foil her master hogback's plan
resulting ultimately in his defeat which
is a nice little narrative trick
proving that hogback lost and was
defeated simply because of who he was
which is always incredibly satisfying
for me as a reader
zorro vs ryuma a couple of things about
this fight my editor brought to my
attention was that the character of
ryuma
is based on a character oda created for
an entirely different one-shot manga
called
monsters which on its own is a neat
little factoid about this battle but
what i loved most about it was how it
was structured you see the entire fight
itself takes place in a sort of
flashback which not only is a unique
way to mix things up in delivering the
conclusion of a fight sequence but it's
also used to tremendous effect
in this particular case the fight begins
strangely enough at the very
end of it with zorro looking as though
he had completely lost
as we continue through the manga what
follows this is as i said earlier the
entire fight taking place in a flashback
the interesting part being that right
now we think that we know the ending
which as i explained in my alabasta
video is something known as dramatic
irony
or at least we think we do throughout
the entire fight we have a sinking
feeling in the back of our minds that
despite zoro's best efforts here
he's destined to lose however as it
happens as a nice swerve
how we interpreted the ending of this
fight scene when we were first shown it
was incorrect zorro despite having a lot
of trouble with this undead samurai
manages to put him away proving that he
is deserving of one day becoming the
greatest swordsman in the land
and so not only did this fight scene
provide a nice little character moment
here and there for zorro
not only did it employ an interesting
format but it also elevated both of the
warriors involved
which isn't a small feat at all and with
this victory under his belt
zoro also returns to the body of brook
his shadow
for the first time in many many years
[Music]
usopp versus perona this fight is
fantastic and in my humble opinion is
the best fight in this entire arc
using established techniques like those
ghosts that inject negative emotions and
a host of goofy things supplied by usopp
this fight serves to demonstrate
why he is such a phenomenally useful
character and
acts on its own as a perfect case study
for how you should use your weaker
characters to great effect in a fight
scene
demonstrated earlier in the arc as the
first creature they see
these ghosts commanded by pironas suck
the joy out of a person leaving them in
an
unmotivated unenthusiastic key on the
floor this was played for laughs a large
number of times throughout the arc on
various characters like sanji luffy and
zorro
rendering them entirely useless
momentarily but in this sequence
in this fight against usopp those ghosts
have zero effect on the sniper as he is
already terrified and as down as he
possibly can be
is tremendously sad but while this works
as a great gag
it also serves to emphasize how utterly
gutsy and courageous usap needs to be at
all times in order to operate while
being so completely
and utterly defeated in his mind it
shows how much he cares for his friends
for him to be able to work through
something like this
on a consistent basis and in addition to
that this fight sequence forces usop to
use his head his lies finally work
and all of his cheap tricks hit their
mark leaving pirona in an emotional heap
the same way
she leaves her opponents it was such a
fun unpredictable and character-rich
sequence
that proved to be an easy highlight
amidst this arc
and okay so i'm about to dive into my
opinions on some things i
didn't like as much i'll try to justify
every conclusion i've come to
as clearly as i can so alright let's
dive in
hey
[Music]
sanji versus the invisible beast guy
okay so i'll start things off with a few
minor things
this might very well be the irish
catholic upbringing that's making me
cringe during these moments or
causing me to find them overly crass but
that one scene where the invisible guy
does some truly despicable things to
nami in the shower
really made me feel uncomfortable i can
see that this could have been a tribute
to those famous shower scenes from
horror films but
geez does this go on for a long time and
is immediately followed by a gag with
usopp i understand that this is meant to
make us hate this invisible leopard
character but i felt as though it took a
few steps too far
considering this is a manga for kids at
the end of the day with that said
however the character who assaulted nami
and robin is confronted by the white
knight sanji later in the arc
during one of the fight sequences now as
you might remember i specifically didn't
like this fight scene and mentioned so
above not necessarily because i thought
it was poorly choreographed or
uninteresting visually i thought it even
had some interesting moments here and
there in terms of character
but unlike the rest of the fights which
served to elevate the characters
involved respectively
this actively made me dislike sanji more
if any of you follow me on twitter
you'll know that my favorite character
in one piece was sanji and i also hated
this invisible character so i was more
than invested in watching him be
destroyed by sanji who leading up to
this fight
expressed rage when he heard the news
about how he treated
and attacked the girls of the straw hat
crew and while he is
angry at this fact it's revealed during
this fight that a large portion of what
made him so intensely angry about it
was that he was also looking
specifically for that devil fruit the
invisible leopard man was using
and in this sequence sanji flat out
admits to being just as bad as this guy
that we all hate
wanting to use it for awful awful things
as well and what's even more confusing
to me is that this is played for laughs
as i said this sort of tainted the
character of sanji for me
he's also a sucker for the ladies so i
hope that gag doesn't get old too fast
yikes called it
perhaps i didn't fully understand him as
a character leading up to this correctly
but
to me up until this point i always saw
him as more of a brock from pokemon type
character
one that idolizes women and wants to
always sweep them off their feet
he saw them as people to fight for and
to die for and this
is a flaw on its own sure but it's a
flaw that comes from a good place
up until this point for me sanji had
been walking this fine line of a lovable
idiot
obsessed with chivalry but in this scene
he openly admits to be as gross as the
character i honestly hated
and to me that made me like him a whole
lot less
taking from him what was for me an
interesting layer of complexity and
replacing it with an extremely
uninteresting
and tired anime trope that i personally
never found particularly funny
again maybe this is the irish catholic
upbringing in me but that sort of stuff
never resonated with me in any
meaningful way now if any of you guys
disagree i'd be interested to hear your
arguments in the comment section down
below or if you really want to at me on
twitter you can do so too
the third act personally i found that
unlike all of the other acts in one
piece that all seemed to have paced
themselves really well for me in the
past
this acts final act really dragged its
feet
up until moria was defeated for me while
i thought the concept of a giant monster
luffy was interesting
forcing the crew to deal with them while
luffy is off getting a super buff power
up i thought that once the personality
of luffy faded into the background he
became the single most boring opponent
in the show for me without a personality
to latch onto
that drives the decisions he's making i
wasn't a big fan he's just a zombie like
every other one and i think oda
recognized that too as
almost immediately after that
personality vanished maurya starts
piloting him like the empty vessel he is
which is good news but unfortunately for
this arc i
wasn't a big fan of this fight with
moria either but that's not to say that
i didn't like aspects of it i
simply don't know very much about moria
as a character
for example unlike alabasa that spent a
considerable amount of time in various
scenes in various scenarios developing
and establishing the rich personality of
croc for us the audience
maurya isn't revealed until halfway
through the story and
is in very few scenes that show his
personality or motivating factors
on the flip side i can imagine a lot of
people don't like his design but
as a character with this specific devil
fruit ability i thought the fact that
his silhouette was so
unique made him a perfect design for
both the theme of this world and a
perfect fit for that ability but by the
time dr hogbach was defeated i felt a
lot of the emotional weight behind the
crimes committed by these bad guys had
been dealt with before even beginning
the fight with moria
but that isn't even my biggest issue
with the character
his moveset seems to come out of nowhere
typically when a devil fruit power is
established the powers are either
explained shown or understood before the
climax decides it needs to depend on
them to work
but in this final fight it honestly felt
as though moria was
inventing powers on the fly to extend
the fight beyond a natural conclusion
so let me explain crocodile could do
fantastical things with his sand powers
but they were
always either foreshadowed or had
something inherently known about sand as
a material used within it like its
ability to dehydrate something we all
know that sand does that
that's an attribute of sand that exists
that people are aware of
and as a result that doesn't necessarily
need to be explained or foreshadowed to
us the audience as it should be
derivative of his particular ability
whereas swapping places with your shadow
as well as a host of random powers
maurya seemed to have
with this particular devil fruit ability
seemed to come out of absolutely nowhere
just to create more trouble than it
should have been at the time these
weren't subversions these were just
pulled out of nowhere and it was all the
more unsatisfying for it for me
now that's not to say there weren't
aspects of this final fight that i
enjoyed tremendously
in fact there's quite a lot i really
enjoyed that moria isn't the typical
cool looking villain but more
importantly i specifically adore that he
takes the combined efforts of all the
straw hats to defeat him at the end of
the day
with several characters like chopper
utilizing what makes them special to
identify weak spots and to form a
strategy to defeat him but even
acknowledging that we get
awesome scenes like this one where robin
outplays him in a physical game of chess
and in a really brutal way too which is
totally elevating her in my favorite
character list but more importantly this
was an incredibly satisfying sequence
because she overcame
in a creative way what we already
understood were the established
parameters of this particular exchange
maurya comes out of nowhere with an
ability that was
not foreshadowed explained or derived
from what we understood about shadows
completely sucking the earned tension
out of the scene and i say that not
because i wanted robin to win per se
i honestly don't really care who gets to
win in this case i only care about how
the narrative in a fight scene adheres
to certain rules in order to achieve a
desired effect
if all the characters did in the scene
was pull out made up moves out of
nowhere all the time
then that would be really boring
what makes a fight scene interesting for
me anyway is the creativity employed by
the author in deriving surprise or
tension utilizing what we already
understood about the scene or characters
involved
in this particular case oda has more
effectively say
you activated my trap card which
honestly really sucked me out of the
entire occasion
luffy also during this section i thought
felt a little weird
i thought the idea of him absorbing the
powers of all the shadows was sort of
cool and
you know sort of kept in theme with the
idea of everyone in this working
together to overcome moria but when he
says
this quote there's only one luffy and
it's me
while voided out on the power of a
hundred other people that aren't luffy
i had a bit of a chuckle i have to admit
but anyway even after this roided out
attack on moria if you thought he was
done at this point you're sorely
mistaken
morgan gets up after seemingly being
defeated for the third time
and absorbs the powers of a thousand
shadows effectively giving himself a
tummy ache defeating himself but perhaps
the most ludicrous part of this entire
fight
was its ending earlier in this arc it's
established that moria can't simply be
defeated for the shadows to all return
to the straw hats and the other people
they were taken from
he needs to voluntarily choose to
relinquish these shadows
and send them back to their respective
owners and at the end of this arc
he decides that the new world will take
care of them and give them
everything they deserve he does this
despite the fact that
everyone is literally seconds away from
being erased
he does this being seconds away from
winning he didn't even need to fight
anymore
he could have quite literally done
nothing and won
but he didn't instead he chose to give
up at literally the last possible second
this is akin to being infinity points up
in the nba
finals with one second left in the clock
forfeit the match
that wasn't what i wanted from this
occasion and
that pretty much covers everything that
i didn't like really and to be honest it
felt a little weird to criticize one
piece so continuously but
hey time for some more peak one piece
that picks up immediately after this
the ending of the arc okay this was
freaking amazing like not at all what i
was expecting especially after the
lukewarm finish i experienced with the
conclusion
of the last fight but this fight
sequence really impressed me
not because it was particularly flashy
though it did have some of its moments
for sure but because of the character
writing that was on display
throughout the development on behalf of
the entire straw hat crew
is abundantly clear so this warlord
bartholomew kuma guy arrives and is just
the most intimidating person we've met
so far he's
completely no nonsense and all about
following the orders of the government
and once his eyes are set on the
unconscious
luffy and the straw hats he
systematically plows through
each and every one of them with little
to no effort
yet in a defiant brilliant panel they
all defiantly scream
that they will never give up on
defending their captain it's a beautiful
moment however moments later with
absolute ease
he renders each and every one of the
straw hats unconscious
well almost everyone
zoro once again steps up to the plate
being an absolute
legend with lines like when disaster
looms you've got to step up or shove off
making excuses isn't going to change
anything if i die here then i wasn't
worth much
to begin with as an absolute last resort
understanding that he can't win in the
situation
zoro offers up his head in place of
luffy's sanji objects to this but very
quickly
zoro shuts him down in accepting this
sacrifice kuma extracts all the
suffering luffy endured during this
battle
and offers it to zorro to hold and bear
for him
resulting in
this arc finishes incredibly strong with
not just moments like i spoke about
regarding zorro but also with delivering
backstories for new additions like
brooke and in a shocking turn of events
that i absolutely did not see coming i'm
serious had you given me a hundred years
i wouldn't have remembered that small
plot line from reverse mountain but as
it turns out
brook is the last surviving crew member
from the rumber pirates
the very pirates that befriended laboon
and left him waiting
over 50 years ago this added for me
much needed complexity to brooke as a
character presenting him as someone that
stresses and worries about keeping his
afro
not necessarily just because he likes it
but because he's actually aware of it
being
possibly the only part of him that
leboon himself will remember
along with one other token that left me
in tears
there's a beautifully intimate scene at
the very end of this arc between luffy
brook
and the piano wherein brooke begins
lamenting over his past what he's lost
and
the story of how he got to where he is
communicated through a
fittingly haunting rendition of a song
by the name of binx's
sung by him and his crew as they fall
away one by one before leaving him
alone it's a beautiful scene that paints
brook as a very lonely soul
feeling isolated and lost in a room
filled with people
but this time it's different he's not
alone and in a very real way this time
he's accepted into the crew by luffy and
so i guess luffy's finally found the
musician he's been looking to recruit
since the beginning of the story
but even that's not the most
entertaining part if you'll believe it
earlier in the story kuma announces that
blackbeard whom we last saw clashing
with ace
is being chosen as crocodile's
replacement as one of the seven warlords
of the sea we also learned that whatever
happened between blackbeard and ace
it resulted in blackbeard getting away
an ace being taken prisoner by the
government
well if that wasn't enough at the very
end of this arc we learned that the
piece of paper ace gave luffy in
alabasta
all those chapters ago is a piece of
verve or life paper
essentially for all intents and purposes
this connects luffy to ace
allowing him to find him more easily and
according to that piece of paper
in luffy's possession ace is barely
hanging on
which is incredibly exciting sad but
exciting and interesting to hear
so i guess that's where we're going next
despite this arc being much less
consistent in terms of entertainment for
me when compared with the rest
i still very much enjoyed my time
towards the beginning and most
definitely after its main events ended
the conclusions to this arc are nothing
short of
harrowing heroic and haunting with zoro
for the first time in a very long while
being the standout character
to be honest the focus has been
primarily on so many other characters in
the past few arcs
that all zorro's done over the last
couple of arcs has speak every now and
again before fighting the second
strongest guy and he does amazingly well
in that role but this arc's conclusion
for me cemented him as one of the
absolute
best fits as luffy's number two as for
brooke someone i honestly didn't enjoy
much of early on due to the crass nature
he was introduced with
very quickly became more of a character
i could sink my teeth into with once
again the conclusion to this arc
managing to flesh out this old bag of
bones all the more
there's a pun for you right there that
hasn't been used i'm now halfway
through my adventure through the high
seas of one piece as i endeavor to catch
up with the rest of the world
and with the nightmare before christmas
style story that was thriller bark now
in the books
despite its downsides i'm still very
happy i checked it out and finished it
there were some truly interesting
touching and well-written scenes
throughout it just so happened to be
dragged down by a very ill-conceived
villain in my opinion with some pacing
issues
join me next week as i continue down the
road on this adventure
and don't forget if you want to support
the channel check out one punch man road
to hero
2.0 using the link in the description
but that'll do it for this video
i've been totally not mark i'll see you
all next week and thank you
so much for watching
you